this past weekend is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza get
that hitter hey boy you got some money
boy
yeah I might have some and if I do have
it I have it in my Ridge wallet
over there over there what's that over
there that's a ridge wallet Ridge wallet
is that special front pocket carry you
know a lot of times things in your back
pocket and you don't even know what's
happening Oh what's happening
change that change your lifestyle get
that front pocket carry that hitter go
to Ridge wallet dot-com slash hitter and
use code hitter at checkout for 10% off
that's code hitter H ITT er for 10% off
at Ridge wallet dot-com slash hitter now
you know I've been using that Ridge for
probably one year ooh no ano and I'm
doing fine and also your ridge that
ridge hitter can can block a bullet tree
so somebody fires a bullet at you close
range maybe your wife or your ex-wife or
your side piece or a man you're seeing
that your wife didn't even know that you
dated mid anything could happen these
days so take care of your money keep it
in the front of your person and that is
with that Ridge wallet Ridge wallet calm
slash hitter and use code hitter for 10%
off today's guest is a young fellow who
you may know him from barstool and if
you don't know what barstool is you're
gonna learn about it it's not just an
Instagram he was a a athlet a petition
an athlete a backup quarterback at
University of North Carolina which a lot
of people didn't know that but you're
gonna know that
and also this man is a unique man and a
novelty man today's guest is Caleb
Presley
[Music]
welcome Kayla Presley how are you man oh
well thank you for having me yeah this
is very exciting yeah well I appreciate
you coming man
you know I know that you work with bar
stool you know and that's a wild
organization and I've been up there I've
been over to their fourth floor office
or seventh floor maybe and it's like 40
dudes inebriated seems like you know for
sure yeah a lot of men a lot of troubled
man I remember I met a couple fellas
maybe closeted kind of guys and kind of
a couple rubenesque boys a lot of guys
who would have been models maybe in like
the 1400s you know a lot of body type
lot of wild body types in there that was
your main takeaways well you always hear
about bar stool like otter [ __ ] you know
that's a shady organization what are
these guys up to yeah they're gonna get
busted for money laundering like you
always hear like witches they're always
on the cusp of things you know yeah it's
not out of the question yeah they're
kind of like the Richard Nixon of the
hum of like online yeah a lot of in a
lot of people don't know what it is
either that's the thing I didn't know
what it was I was like I didn't know if
it was gonna be like one of those drunk
buses that's going around town and like
you're gonna peddle it yeah so so
explain to people a little bit who don't
know a barstool is let's start right
there I mean barstool is is what you
said it is kinda it's interesting
because there's it's a lot of different
things at the at the top level it's just
a lifestyle brand okay I mean that's at
the end of the day and it started as a
men's lifestyle brand now we got so many
girls that are like so successful that
are doing more doing better than the
guys that it's it's hard to say it's a
men's lifestyle brand only but that's
how it started
right and that's what it is it's means
sports media but it's also like you were
there you kind of you got a feel for the
whole gauntlet of there's a lot of entry
points yeah there's a lot of things you
can do yeah there's a lot of entry
points that's a good that's a good point
that's a that's a good entry point right
there they had um yeah one thing I
thought was interesting like I got it
got it because I didn't know what to
expect and literally I mean the elevator
then the doors
open yeah and then then you're in it
yeah then you're in it yeah and it's
like um it looked like about 1/12 or
1/16 of it maybe 1/12 of a gymnasium
floor space so just like the free-throw
line
yeah Lin yeah it was basically the paint
the paint yeah and then wall-to-wall
sideways like it was a pretty decent
amount of space
yeah you get a three office yeah yeah or
if you're a Latino and you're playing on
your lunch break
well it's 17 on 17 the local playground
you could get off a 6 pointer you know a
lot of those guys will fire off that six
pointer but yeah the doors open and I'm
like holy [ __ ] now I'm in the you know
in the liver of bar stole my head and it
was pretty wild yeah it's a the liver is
not doing well yes yeah we're moving
offices next time you come back whenever
we get we'll get a new office and it's
the thing about barstool dude is I
started working there right at college
right I went to North Carolina for
college I played yeah oh yeah I know you
played backup quarterback there you play
quarterback sorry I mean I know I was
backup I was definitely backup who were
you back up to over there so I was back
up a lot of people so I went to college
with the most famous guy went to college
with quarterback wise as mr. Biscay the
quarterback of Chicago Bears I don't
know how much you follow for yeah I like
the Bears actually and I thought true
Biscay was a Ricci pick but I think he
has a lot I think has some upside I
think in the next two years he's gonna
have to definitely show it or he's gonna
be we had a good he had a good year last
year he did he want my best friends I
was roommates with him call Wow we had
queen bunk beds wow what is that it's a
bunk beds but queen-size so it's like
book beds for men oh why don't we have
that Nick I'm down yeah King fuck'em
yeah you guys live together uh uh sure
Nick sleeps in here sometimes and I want
him to feel alone so we'll put an extra
bar or throw an extra Judy was great for
bonding dude I got to be honest like I I
never felt closer to somebody yeah it's
no one he was always under me yeah yeah
I had your back or I stopped [ __ ] you
you better know how you were sleeping
and uh yeah did he feel a lot of
pressure when she got up to the where
he's at now dude I mean he obviously he
didn't say to me like dude I'm feeling a
lot of pressure right now but I think
how could you not yeah at first
especially because he was such a high
pick he was the number two pick and he
probably didn't expect that yeah I mean
it was crazy I was at the draft with him
oh wow and so when we got to the draft
kind of hearing cuz they have all these
agents and they're like kind of telling
you what to expect like where he's gonna
go and he's from Cleveland and so the
first pick was Cleveland and so it was
kind of like a hometown story yeah and
they'll even we'll take any quarter I
mean they'll take [ __ ] they took nine
quarterback I mean at that point they
would have took a water see today that
could have played yeah but uh so we were
like thinking I want him to go to
Cleveland cuz it's like yo if you go to
Cleveland you win four games they'll
build a statue of you yeah you're a
legend yeah and you don't really have to
do much other than that and you can go
home for dinner or whatever but he did
anyways he was a number one ranked
quarterback coming out which was crazy
because there was like deshaun Watson
was in the same year yeah Patrick
mahomes was in the same year which is
which is dude that's a bunch of good
quarterback so he was the number one guy
though it's gonna go down historically
as a great class I think all those guys
could be Superbowl champions when it's
all said and done but anyways we were
hearing where he was gonna go and I
think it was like Kansas City was one of
the other ones that we heard but then
Chicago traded up for that pick and then
so when they traded and we found out
yeah it was crazy and honestly I'm gonna
keep it 100% real with you I don't
remember what your question was
yeah it all started with you saying you
got a the job at Barksdale right out of
college and then we just moved to
football you got a right out of college
it so when you're there are you telling
guys I was like hey you know I'm his
backup you know pick me you know first
dude I never I never backed him up I was
always in front of him because I was
older ah
so he was a freshman when I was like a
junior and so I was actually second
string when he was red shirting did he
ever have to come out cuz like his shoe
was undone and yet if I can go in there
dude I don't know how else to tell you
this but I was in front of him oh oh so
you started I was second string right
but he was a freshman he was red
shirting so he wasn't even like in the
mix oh wow like there was another guy
that was giving me problems that was in
front of me
mark we swill yems and that's a darker
guy and that was a darker guy and still
is and today right now who's better
right now to you and Mark we's I mean
dude he still tried to play in the AAF
oh wow did he which was that new Wow
good for him man it's a tough thing dude
it was tough did you see what happened I
know it I just know it went under I
watched San Antonio some got a shot in
the parking lot yeah I just saw that
first hit
that everybody was going crazy about
that first game but I didn't stick I
mean honestly I don't know a lot about
other than it went under and I had a lot
of teammates who were playing well
playing on teams and they just like they
got like charged for the hotels yeah did
you know us like you got two waters and
yours for those as well yeah and Mark
wheats is one of them so it's hard for
me to say that he's that I'm better than
him is he still playing he's still
playing which I haven't thrown a
football in a long time and at the end
of the day dude I really was never much
of a physical specimen I was always more
mental that the the sharp yeah of the
brain yeah right that brain I was how I
got there
well you do Don I used to be from the JP
low-spin when he played at um Tulane
mm-hmm and he was more physical and I
think he was you know I think he was
50/50 on the mental side which a lot of
guys are less right so maybe that he was
good probably oh dude I met Aaron Brooks
one time at a buffet and he didn't know
how a buffet worked and he was and this
was years after he'd been on the st. so
he was probably 1090 mental he threw
that football backwards at one time yeah
he did oh he throw it at anybody dude if
he knew you in the stands one time he
saw Joe Warren in this he thought he saw
Joe horn in the stands and it was just a
fan with a jersey on yo so you're a huge
Saints fan man I'm a big Saints fan man
yeah what about that I love the Bears to
man my mother uh Wow ungrateful girl my
mother grew up in Illinois so I'm a big
I'm a big Bears because that's how they
used to play football how he just threw
it backwards like yeah you used to be
able to go for that the old days do you
miss any of that I mean it sounds like
you went right from something that's a
really big thing football to like was
barstool as big then when you got right
no and that's kind of I think where my
thought process started with the
question was that when I first started
at barstool dude it was like you know as
a guy who his name's Dave portly oh yeah
I've seen him eating the pizza eating
the pizza he's awesome is he awesome
awesome
he's uh he's very polarizing yeah I
could see that but duties that he's that
he's real which is like for me
personally if you're real I'm good okay
that's he is who he is and he's not he's
not putting up one thing over here on
the internet and then he's not acting a
different way that's how he is but
anyway so he started it and he hit me up
in college because we played Duke on a
Thursday night and they did a special I
mean you know ESPN will sometimes do a
special during one that to come back
from timeout and they'll run a special
yeah so ESPN did a special on me and he
saw it he was kind of a funny thing
because I was this is a whole nother
story but I was my senior year the
supervisor of morale yeah I heard about
that for our team I know about that yeah
used to so use really to cheer you like
a it you're like an infiltrate someone
who's infiltrated the team but you're
also like a low-key like the James Bond
of [ __ ] cheerleaders yeah exactly
dude I mean that's honestly that was
when I knew I knew fake news in America
was gonna be a problem are you really
yeah because uh because I really wasn't
honestly the supervisor morale at all
right but I was just hanging out one day
during uh it was like during the summer
during training camp and I was just
hanging out and the girl from USA Today
was there to interview our coach coach
Fedora mm-hmm and so I was hanging out
when the offices that I had they had a
free office and I knew the people I've
been there for four years right yeah and
then the USA Today girl was there I was
like he'll tell her that uh that I'm
like supervising all y'all's morale and
that this is gonna be a new position I
had and I had someone whisper in her ear
on her way out she was like you mind if
I talk to them yeah because then it's
like a secret now she got a tip dude she
did an interview with me for like 20
minutes this girl named Nicole Auerbach
was shout-out to her you really started
my entire career in a out there they
call it a color na which is also
Narcotics Anonymous which is a group on
Pardo yeah so she wrote this article
which is a USA Today this was off duty I
just met I had someone tell her as she
was walking around the building that I
was a fake job and she wrote the next
day article in USA Today saying it was
real and then after that it was real oh
yeah man I love I can relate to that I
one time my girlfriend her mom when I
would tell us you was the women's
athletic director and some girl some
girl on the LSU soccer team told me that
their team was having to take having to
take creatine that's when creatine came
out was that big hitter bra I'm saying
you didn't take create a was making baby
milk hard in the tit like it was doing
bad stuff you know baby's revving the
[ __ ] you know really squeeze the tit
to get something out of it thick milk
and oh I took it dude but he said that
there was
but anyway I one of the girls on the
soccer team told me that the girls on
the soccer team had to take it the coach
made him yeah right right so next thing
you know I'll put all these flowers up
around campus one night the coach's name
was Fotopoulos I think he ended up
marrying a famous female soccer player
but I wrote these times itself atop a
Hitler and put them all over campus
next thing you know I got a couple of my
friends that were H cappers bro a couple
real handicaps vans and everything you
know I'm saying people that were going
with D people at fifty-fifty on if they
were gonna live through their diploma
you know right so when I got them to
come out in wheelchairs and everything
and like assistant vans and pick it the
next morning
so my girlfriend's momma's woman's a boy
a way to pick up the crew teen to pick
it yeah like outside of the women's
athletic like no more pretty yet no more
free it's like you're making crea tits
that's what's one of the sounds said
like just really vague [ __ ] I don't
quit dirty and up that these other
livers yeah the delivers the ovaries we
were [ __ ] profits right right so next
thing you know those news coverage out
there there's like handicapped kids I'm
just hearing like an literally if
there's one point where the mom comes
down she's like what in the [ __ ] is
going on Theo like you stayed at my
house this weekend why don't you say
there was an issue because I was seeing
her daughter and at that point you heard
like this van come up this super
handicap [ __ ] like a two-storey like
this dude was a handicap of flex and you
know and like he'd have [ __ ] stay
over you know and he heard like we got
reinforcements and that's what you can
do like damn this [ __ ] was getting real
and anyway we made a fake news story out
of what was going on
did it cause a rift in your own yes she
and I yeah and then they found some I
was using uh I think test 200 at the
time and I left some [ __ ] dirty you
know dirty hypodermic needles at their
house it was just a bad weekend overall
but what a hypocrite yeah to your point
I wonder if the mom ever thought that
yeah I just thought like well [ __ ] yeah
I'm in a dorm of course I can do
steroids you can't make these chicks do
you know
anyway so you ended up becoming the
supervisor of morale right which was uh
you know like I said it was kind of fake
but it was dude I was I was giving
speeches I mean I was and I was elevated
to the type of character dude I'm not
kidding I was in a bro the height of my
entire college career was not
necessarily because I'm like a pervert
or or you know I'm like sex crazy or
anything like that but just when I knew
that I had I had kind of made it for
college I'm not talking about life I'm
just talking about in college you ever
seen the move like Van Wilder yeah yeah
I just watched it a month ago right so
I'm kind of like thinking like I made it
was I got to give a speech dude to this
this sorority called Zeta mmm-hmm
which is like at Carolina was one of the
top sororities and I got to give them a
speech at their banquet about like
they're about to like graduate dude I
was about to graduate I was doing school
speech about like what they should do
like a like a commencement speech yeah
and I was still in school what else that
dude like that was inside which
all-girls I was inside their sorority
house mm-hmm and I was giving a speech
it's online I mean you can watch the
speech I'm not sure if it was you know I
don't know if you would move you but
yeah it moved me yeah you know uh so at
that point then you coming out of school
you kind of run a little bit of a high
then because that kind of happened
toward the end of school yeah totally
right totally and then so that's also
when Barstow offered me a job in like so
they saw that and they reached out
they're like oh this is a guy that we
cry use right and then I started like I
would host some yet look look I mean
this is Jesus do you want to watch it no
no a minute I don't know if we should
watch it let's go maybe a lot so by
nature of that I've got and then with a
lot of older men just go oh you got a
bunch of Breaking and Entering in your
phone yeah I just came back from Europe
didn't laughing though you said there is
something to be said for like people
using those cliches because it is it's
something deeper than your mind it's a
feeling it this is a time out there this
is the time my life went uh you must've
went to Amsterdam I was watching a lot
of Russell Brand clothes and by the way
there what is Russell Brand is he gonna
[ __ ] admit he's in the guy I say
something yeah okay first of all this
claim a russell brand new at this
especially this time i'm not kidding
loved him at this time yeah he's
probably my number one like who's your
number one person if they're like--they
oh we can introduce you this person you
can hang out them for the day hmm let me
think about that probably either maybe
mmm [ __ ] I don't know man
I was a big Michael Lane of him but he
died people know that and then outside
of that maybe maybe a little Wayne but I
think I get tired might be way too
badass boosie's are going Wayne for me
too but uh anyways damn Wayne but Wayne
isn't easy when I mean everybody would
pick him maybe you know it was like
right place right time like just killing
it right when it mattered but uh and
that in you met Russell Brand no of
anyways I'm sorry so so Russell brands
my number one right I love Russell Brand
just I don't know what you know I could
I would have to think about why he's
motivational he's motivational he's
smart he's kind of counterculture he I
don't know I think he's hilarious a made
love to Katy Perry he was banging
everybody yeah I mean at one point my
life I thought that was super cool yeah
nothing is not cool shout out to Russell
Brand anyways dude so he's my number one
so I come out here to LA hm
and I go to my girlfriend works at
SoulCycle mhm in New York and so I've
been to a few classes so I know it's a
good way to like kind of if you do a
long flight kind of reestablish your
equilibrium oh wow you know I'm saying
sweat it out hmm and so I went to
SoulCycle
there was probably four people in my
class five people in West Hollywood one
on Russell Brand one of them was Russell
bringing this morn this morning yes and
would you do dude I don't I so suck on
my ass off dude I don't know I just
tried my hardest I didn't talk was it
rankings on the thing what do you mean
only on third for now I will who's his
first class ever sure he always says
that I bet to get [ __ ]
did he seem like he what did he seem
like what was his vibe like awesome he's
he he to me he has like this type of
presence where did I win psalms speak
one time when he came to New York he was
just like speaking yeah but don't let
anybody speak they let [ __ ] Kayla
Presley speaking of [ __ ] Zeta comenzó
that's true that's true and this was in
like Brooklyn too which is like that's
awesome
near open-mike but uh did your girl say
that he hit on her no no she wasn't
there I just knew I had that
she's not here I do just know that it'll
help from a plane fly so I did yeah I
just wanted to do some exercise I didn't
want to be like uh you know I come over
from the flight right and dude he came
in and he walked right by me like and I
didn't say anything to him because I
mean from Barstow and I'm sure your
times a million but from Barstow there
are certain areas especially colleges
where you know they're people come up to
you all the time so you I feel like from
those experiences I've learned a little
bit about like what I would do if I did
see a Russell Brand right and in this
scenario I was like I'm not gonna bother
you felt the vibe this isn't the vibe to
this there's not the right time to buy
time right all right look it's a
self-conscious he's in a class now he
has to bike hard his first class oh yeah
but man he's a legend you know and
that's made my whole trip where do you
feel like when you saw him did it feel
like he was smart did it feel like did
he have perfume I like did his you know
him did you get any I didn't get any
scent did you get any vibe you know any
feel he's the type of guy that I think
life moves like a little bit slower for
him like when he looked at me I had to
look away before he did we had eye
contact but it was like he was kind of
seeing things like he was a hummingbird
oh wow I could see that he could just
kind of he he knew I recognized him but
he probably knows everyone recognizes
them yeah so he saw me you know I saw
him I was like oh I like looked away
because I didn't want him to feel
uncomfortable yeah that's fair but I
know he has a great vibe he doesn't have
any eye color though his eyes are just
uh yeah he was he was nude in there yeah
I mean was he really he I don't mean no
in the eyes yeah he just he just came in
are you talking about the actual color
there yeah he said if she wears a lot of
eye makeup oh he does oh that seems cool
does he and how much though it anywhere
if he starts making flames off the side
of my balls then I'm [ __ ] in dude you
got to do some research because back in
the day he was like on heroin and his
hair was huge and ya know I know he does
all I mean I [ __ ] guys anymore though
I follow him on Instagram it's very
motivational I just I don't know
sometimes it seemed a little bit too
much ego for me you know but then also I
don't know if maybe that's just my ego
telling me that I shouldn't try and
relate to someone you
I think that what he's doing now I've
been falling for probably five years
it's probably the least ego wow thing
he's done check back in then because I
think that he's probably if there was a
while when he was doing like a daily
series that was getting like a million
plus hits a day on YouTube and people
really they've gravitate towards him
yeah he's like a cult leader pretty much
yeah and I would you know I would
probably join but anyways he but I think
what he's doing now I don't think a lot
of people are interested I think there's
a there you know he's still doing
numbers he's huge but he's super good at
talking but yeah I think he's really cut
his views because he's talking about
things that are important to him which I
suspect yeah you said that that's when
you realize fake news started Oh
whenever you did the miswrote are they
and then after USA Today wrote it then I
mean you could probably pull this up to
not that you need to but everyone wrote
it I mean it was in every paper I did a
spot-on he ain't about it so people just
took this one thing and then it and then
it became real and then I really was
they were selling t-shirts with my face
on them on Franklin Street in Chapel
Hill right and so I mean I wasn't
complaining but I was like man we're
gonna have a problem right we had a call
from a guy who really affected well
let's hear that then hey Co this is
Scott from North Carolina I'm 24 years
old and I've had season tickets to
Carolina football since I was like two
years old and Calif that year that they
went to ACC title and that team man some
special and seeing him come out and the
different pro players jerseys every week
was like the highlight of the week like
this he's gonna wear it this week
and I just want him to know like he was
very important nothing for the overall I
come robbery and excitement Nikko goes
on for a minute wait why'd you cut it no
you know you were like a real king there
man I must've really went five and seven
I think right which is very good for UNC
or Duke football either one of those
yeah me playing football Carolina's kind
of like like being a sushi chef at a
chocolate cheesecake it's like you know
they might want to Sue's you but they
didn't come for the football is for the
basketball yeah I'm trying to think like
did you uh and so now you're in with
barstool yeah you're over there and it's
going like I'm hung out with Francis
barstool when I awesome
yeah yeah France is really really neat
man awesome guy it's always interesting
because was that your first kind of like
like looking into barstool Oh at all I
just seen things on the app and I
thought they are on Instagram I just
seen like oh it's funny it's my stuff I
mean that's a whole nother and I almost
got murdered off the Instagram oh really
um yeah do people take it what people
someone took something too seriously
well I had a young lady the stalking me
for actually probably about a year and a
half she's she'll send she's created
probably about eight different accounts
and she are you at the Comedy Store
tonight are you here you hear Ali Wong
has an alleged stalker mm-hm and she's
so she always uses a fake name when she
doesn't stand up but it's the same fake
name I think it's just because she
doesn't she doesn't want to sell tickets
in an area so then she can save her
marketability nice more yeah smart which
I get it yeah but it's definitely like I
mean people get stalked did you get
stalked or did you get no well so what
the thing is is just huge I would say
the most people who know barstool the
way that they've got into it now was so
big you should be just like Bossin
whenever I found out about it it was in
North Carolina I had no idea what it was
because it's just Boston but now it's so
big and the reason why I think it grew
so fast one of the main reasons was the
Instagram yeah and the so there's just
so many followers of it so what we'll do
with Barstow is really it's a curated
page of of things that I think they feel
like fit into the brand of like what
would a a guy who's our age like right
you know 18 to 35 that what's that
what's that guy won't want to see right
if funny videos whatever nothing to not
Russell Brand trying to change your life
you're something funny right right yeah
just something to take it yeah
just take 30 seconds out of your day
that's pretty entertaining right and
that's kind of what the the thought
process is because really Barstow is not
the Instagram I mean it is Instagram but
it's so much bigger and the real things
that we do and we were content creators
right so that's not really what barstool
is but that's what people's inroad to it
so we try to get people to the barstool
world by every once in a while we'll put
some of our content on there you know
just to show them and not unless it's
something good I think whenever you came
to barstool they posted what you did at
bars so on the bar so Instagram right
that was real original bar so content I
mean it was just you talking but right
it was bar so content yeah yeah it was
fun I wouldn't have done that content if
I wasn't there right and in that moment
and so anyway so a lot of one thing that
I do for Barstow I do a ton of different
things but one thing I have done over
the years is do like red carpets if I
can get access oh yeah I seen you in
interviewing uh maybe I'll not Albert
Brooks who is Antonio Brown Antonio
Brown Baker Mayfield Le'Veon Bell yeah
that clip we watched I interviewed all
your boy Alvin come here did you really
yeah he's a good guy think he seem like
a good guy
now I noticed the ego start to change
over these players you see in the first
year they don't have any jewelry the
second year you know they look like a
bull with [ __ ] diamonds hanging out
you know it's like it's definitely
interesting how that how things start to
change
yeah a bee gets accused of having a lot
of ego did he seem like it whenever you
met him he's gotta go
yeah yeah Antonio Brown yeah yeah yeah
he's definitely super cocky nah I'm not
saying it's a bad way it's now a good
way to be as a football player right
I've served him well I mean he's
probably one of the best receivers ever
I saw my Super Bowl he had a yellow
mustache oh wow yeah no but so anyways
at the Super Bowl is when it was no I
was interviewing me goes yeah and so and
the me goes for some reason I find
myself in the same room as the me goes
all the time like whatever whatever
reason it's just something that keeps
happening to matter date triplets other
this black guys I thought it was one guy
for a long time he goes yeah the one guy
upset is always chasing that [ __ ] what
so listen so that I'm talking to him and
and we have kind of like a little bit of
history but this year he he just
famously cheated on cardi B right
because it him and cardi B were together
right and he had just very famously it's
like and I asked a question about it but
I was like you know it's one thing in my
mind that was rationalized I was like
you know it's one thing to like ask
someone about their personal life it's
their person if it's their personal life
but do it if you're if you're dating
Gwyneth Paltrow and you cheat on her and
we all know about it and I don't know
why I choose chose her bad choice um I
feel like it's almost kind of fair game
to ask on a red carpet so anyway she had
just cheated famously on cardi B so I
when there migos were coming I asked him
I said and the Super Bowl was Patriots
and
who the Patriots be I'm just trying to
Ryan Rams oh I asked him I said did Bill
Belichick or any of the Patriots reach
out to you to see the best ways to cheat
in Atlanta Wow and as soon as I said it
I was like probably that was probably
not not super smart yeah and he looked
at me he kind of gave me like a death
stare anyways
I didn't get killed that night and I
wasn't worried about getting killed
right
but then that clip got isolated and
posted without my knowledge or am I
asking on the bar so Instagram because
it was a funny clip okay as the question
was pretty funny
it is good honey and the way he looked
back was like oh this guy's can get
murdered and then they posted it and
then I had like it was going viral and
it was like at caleb presley at offset
at cara presley at offset so like you
know he's definitely gonna see this row
and i'm for some reason I'm always
around these guys like I'm not really
I'm not really trying to to go down like
that yeah there's other ways that I
would choose to go and do you think you
have you seen him again since then I
haven't but what I did is I was like I
talked to two people who I know in like
the rap communities that work in rap and
I was like am I had a real liability
here right for you you know should I hit
this out yeah hit or I mean if that's
what their musics talking about people
make fun of me but that's I mean that's
what they say right that's what they say
in the music I mean the one guy looks
like maybe you should work at a tuxedo
shop I can't touch side of town it seems
like maybe the toughest time that
they've been through but I don't know
that much about him
you know yeah well anyway so I was
asking and he was like in two different
sources that didn't know I asked each
other we're like you probably would be
better off if he took that down damn so
I had him take it down a barstool
from the bar so Instagram and Wow and
and I was worried too because the year
before I had the same event sent me goes
where they're performing in and the
Kapernick was on the streets mm-hmm and
I asked the I asked offset this time a
year before I was like have you seen a
clip of him proposing to cardi B when
they first proposed oh no I haven't I
seen I think where he where he gets
rejected on stage with all the flowers
is that one I don't I don't think it
might be though because he's on stage
and then he doesn't take a knee he like
squats right when he when he asked her
exactly this is there right here no she
said no she says yes I think yeah I
think that was later I know what you're
talking about he tried to like approach
her on at a concert at a different time
and she like turned him down
yeah they meet up with the concerts a
lot yeah it's a lot of staged it seems
like yeah maybe he asked her offstage
and then once he knew off set off stage
and he asked and what she knew he was
like I'm gonna do it on stage yeah I
mean he was upset this is just still
image I was just showing him oh wait
anyways so I asked him then I was like
when you I noticed that you did kind of
a half squats that have taken a knee
when you proposed a car to be was that a
shot at Colin Kaepernick or you just
supporting the troops and uh and then he
was huh and then that night they donated
$10,000 to Colin Kaepernick like two
hours later Wow I posted on their
Instagram because I think they thought
that I was loved maybe that was gonna
come out somehow yeah Wow funny so I
kind of like raised money in a weird way
yeah and Colin Kaepernick got paid too
once they guys once the lawsuit all came
through oh he's good yeah he's good do
you think that that whole thing was so
bizarre huh do you think it was all just
a big ruse the whole time like just was
he just trying to get paid what I heard
was that he met a girl who was like way
like in like um civil rights and stuff
like that and that's really what kind of
started him down that road yeah I
believe you
yeah I feel like that's a good way to
get into civil rights do you think he
was that good of a quarterback I thought
he was good he wasn't starting he wasn't
playing right when all that happened I
mean it wasn't like he was starting and
then all that happened but he was good
and to me like the question is should it
be on NFL roster to me he's like a temp
Tebow right where he's good enough to
play right but he's not good enough for
the distraction yeah yeah I agree if he
didn't if Tim Tebow wasn't Tim Tebow he
could have been a backup quarterback in
NFL yeah you think Tim Tebow brought
that on himself are they just the media
which is like a lot of a lot of the
media is kind of anti-christian that
they kind of beat him down a little bit
by like bringing so much attention that
it by giving him so much attention that
it kind of sunk him I think like
religion is something a lot of people
care about right and it was a story that
was
obviously doing numbers every single
time they ran it hmm so so it just kept
to these kept rocks so they kept running
it finding new ways to run it yeah just
like if you watch the news it's always
bad yeah cuz those stories do numbers
people like those stories yeah so yeah
they were refresh yes somebody gets a
you know a thing of fresh eggs or
something nobody gives a [ __ ] right show
exactly if somebody's like Oh Brandon
got a couple fresh eggs from his buddy
two people gonna click on that yeah they
might see a lot of people if that's just
the headline it just depends on the
demographic you're running at yeah I
guess hurry to man as an internet
article that probably could do well yeah
for a while I think yeah Filipino
audience would go big man they're really
into [ __ ] eggs their eggs are bad
again - do you see that
uh-uh they said eggs are bad again oh
yeah it's every it's just scientific
study or whatever you believe in science
or not and be honest with me uh you know
what dude I am a sucker for science dude
are you really a sucker in a bad way
like I'll you know you tell me anything
dude like I was eating eggs everyday
read that no eggs
wow I'm like I'm a type of guy like I
bought a but a lot of Bitcoin yeah yeah
I currently have lost about $4,000 in
Bitcoin yeah so that's like is that scam
I mean who's getting popped for that
dude this is how how stupid I am dude I
bought more Wow after we went down oh I
had a lunch with this guy no-name
Bitcoin party he dead first of all
Jewish guy let's go ahead they're busy
Marty no he's not Jewish but I know he's
got the money he's got your money
Bitcoin Marty go and and I was and I
just really want to catch up with him
because since the crash I didn't want
him you know I hadn't talked to him
since the crash the crash since every
[ __ ] white dude just out of college
lost $2,000 to the Bitcoin bro I didn't
want him to I didn't want him to think
that I didn't want to talk to an hour
because Bitcoin right now no he meant
more than me are you saying yeah this is
beyond big this is bigger than busy
that's all thirty four thirty if twenty
others are killing the other one it's
gonna be called beyond Bitcoin and so I
just wanted to hit him up and and so I
had like a little lunch with him and
this is not that long ago this is like
four months ago three months ago and he
sold me the dream again
and I bought another one damn what's
this one called it's just one of the
regular ones I bought the regular
Bitcoin that's how actually I lost all
my money in the first time was uh I
bought guava yeah that's what I yeah and
that's when you're in trouble and that's
how I lost my money dude you can't hear
me no the chocolate yeah its people
people hate smacking smacking it sorry
guys I just had a little chocolate yeah
we dude I'm on I'm a sucker for science
I mean I'll take it if you tell me
something right now and you don't even
have anything to back it up I probably
would just trust you based on you got
strong forearms it looks like oh that's
most of my life dude he's probably
believing stuff that I just cuz they
think about it everything that's going
on is just [ __ ] that got kind of passed
down kind of baked into society yeah for
sure
you know I will tell Caleb that we had
dr. Perlmutter in just right after that
egg study came out and we asked him
about it and he was like like look into
the methodology it's it's debunk he's a
big still firm believer in eggs and he
had a number one bestseller on nutrition
so we're back on it yeah you're back on
next and you'd say no more you're back
I'm back almost I'm better so how long
will you be out here in LA are you
working are you I'm going right back for
bar stool we have a I don't know when
this comes out but we have them up it
comes out tomorrow I mean I'm sorry next
Thursday okay sirs day well this weekend
we have a rough and rowdy which is this
that's right and that's the thing that
you host over here right we yeah we do
it more than we do it more than once
it's about every couple months it
started in West Virginia and what it is
it's just normal dudes who fight each
other they sign up it's amateur boxing
is it whites or not anybody do white
people do it is it white oh is it
predominantly white yeah but we do there
are a few everybody can get in it
anybody can get in it we don't we don't
have just whites in it but uh you know
there are mostly whites yeah but just
based off the states that we do it in
right you know West Virginia is where
it's best though and that's where we're
going back we had done a couple we did
in Jacksonville Florida yeah it since
its we doing in places where you can
find someone who wants to do it oh yeah
people want to fight fight and when I
was in college somebody would they had a
bear people bring this bear that had
been declawed and you could [ __ ] him
wrestle it and then they had this thing
I didn't do this but somebody had a
group called [ __ ] fistfights and it was
game
would fight each other in a wrestling
room and and you did that to know what
if I can lost but I think I would have
ranked dude a printer but you could
watch him embed on him and stuff and it
was like a big night at the bar you know
cockfighting yeah
yeah it's like there's an original
cockfight economy and it wasn't I mean
they called themselves [ __ ] fistfights it
wasn't like people were like oh this is
what this is right now
all other people in the streets called
it you know possibly game in fighting
each other I was in Louisiana and did
you go to you went to LSU yo and tell us
you ever been to Fred's oh yeah I've
been to Fred's do one of my buddies who
used to be one of the owners got a diet
he got hit by lightning right out front
of it in front of Fred's yeah pretty
cool man Fred's is the type of place
that would happen yeah I went down there
and with [ __ ] wrestling match inside
the barn oh wow Frazier is probably my
favorite bar in the tigon really yeah it
gets [ __ ] dirty anything can happen
in there yeah we did a tour like when I
first got at college it was the six
months I lived in a bus Houston an RV oh
wow
I just went to different SEC schools
during the football season so I went to
pretty much every SEC school uh-huh and
Fred's in LSU are definitely top which
one had the most aggravating accent cuz
look I mean I'm not look I'm from
Louisiana I get it southern accent but
it gets [ __ ] a little it gets a
little questionable you know in
Louisiana in certain areas in certain
places whether a place you notice where
they accent like sometimes a Mississippi
you go there by Ole Miss and some of the
girls you're like what is this a yeah
like a stage play or something this
Tennessee Williams yeah and then you got
the people at Mississippi State who were
trying to talk like that but they're not
quite good at yeah you know start gana
stand so everybody calls that place yeah
just like a big strip mall I got pinkeye
my 22nd birthday uh him and three other
guys got pinkeye and we woke up with it
in Starkville anyways it it basically
it's just a stark we'll have you never
been is just like a big strip mall with
a it's like you know online colleges
yeah and then how they just like
University of Phoenix will set up like
next to a subway yeah it's it's like
that except it's a real school and the
city state but yeah I woke up there dude
in a freaking we were in the bus and we
all had pinkeye
well and so I went to the doctors which
was also in a strip mall yeah and a lot
of camouflage over there too
yeah they don't want you assume that's
cool they got a lot of camo Mississippi
State Theo got pinkeye in Pittsburgh oh
yeah I got pick on base burger yeah and
I've got a ping on a lot of places but
this is a hot strand over there I think
Pittsburgh near Starkville oh yeah
there's a [ __ ] strong strip it's like
one of those things where it's like you
go to Mexico you have to get used to
water like you almost I think if you go
to start so you get pinkeye yeah if it's
your first time yeah yeah yeah you go
back you'll be fine yeah yeah but if
it's your first time you you're more
than likely gonna get pinkeye um well
speaking of states man in different
areas we got we're headed into the final
we're in the Elite Eight right now Nick
you want to get us into that if you
don't mind brother yeah we're in the
Elite Eight of this past weekend state
Wars March Madness or March
late April Madness and we're gonna take
it to the conclusion we will have seven
seven matchups to go and we're gonna
start in the regional final in the
Midwest
number three Michigan verse number one
Illinois shut up so we're gonna finish
this thing yeah [ __ ] what it on you're
an esteemed esteemed what and honored
boy Nate bargatze
Jim Gaffigan and Brian Cowen have all
done the first four rounds oh yeah the
champion Kayla Presley the only actually
Jim Gaffigan I think played college
sports yeah and you did so you the you
two are actually athletes but and Bryan
Callen is in seniors I think oh I was
yeah I think he's in handle making I
don't know what he does I was gonna say
about rough and rowdy we Jionni likes
the box we should get him in rough and
rowdy sometimes yeah with your little
Gianni in there dude he's a little
Italian your guys wizard you guys would
love it and you should have him do it
because no you should do you should uh
if you want to announce it yeah we had
bill Bert did two of them really and so
what I do is I do like the sideline
report yeah yeah and then we have guys
who call the fights mmm so bird did he
did two of them with us he's awesome
he's so funny and then we have Dave the
pizza guy oh and then a big cat who's he
has this big podcast called part of my
take he's hilarious and we'll have a
guest and if you want to have him fight
you could probably pick up like a nice
check just to announce it I'd be fun man
yeah I would really be interested in
doing that I like to watch people fight
and say stuff in the background
do they have um who's that guy I just
went in Francis his buddy in the in the
morning that doesn't show with him um
Willie yeah I was awesome Willie Cologne
yeah yeah that guy's funny man he's got
cool hair alright let's get into this
and we got matchup one did you say Nick
yep matchup won three Michigan versus
number one in Illinois yeah man thanks
for being here and thanks for helping us
out with this for Caleb
alright so Michigan Illinois so we're
just gonna declare a winner and you've
been through all these and you know kind
of how they I mean it's these two have
never played each other there's the
breakdown we got a video right here from
me yeah I'm glad you said that
this guy looks exactly like Jesus Dennis
Michigan versus Illinois I was born and
raised in Illinois I went to college at
Western Michigan go Broncos
so I gotta go with Michigan Illinois
could anybody really name any other
cities or towns in Illinois besides
Chicago it's all suburbs it's all
flatland the politics are corrupt last
year thirty thousand people left the
state of Illinois because of taxes and
we're too divided we don't even like
each other's baseball teams I was one
the few people who was rooting against
the Cubs in the World Series because I'm
that much of a South Sider go White Sox
with Michigan you got all that land they
are united on all fronts they got the
Great Lakes and if it's any consolation
me a person of Illinois choosing
Michigan is just further proof that
Michigan takes it gang gang dude first
of all holy [ __ ] dude obviously I came
in someone about 20 years ago here this
guy's down unbelievable and this is me
if I was a little bit better looking
that's even the how does he not mention
one time he looks like me with
better-looking eyes God I'll drink that
[ __ ] kids blood
well that's it good so this is an
Illinois case I have [ __ ] first I think
that's the first time we've had that
yeah he's inside er he was a cider
trading this is that Martha Stewart [ __ ]
right here that guy oh we got it we got
an Illinois supporter awesome podcast
brother new listener thanks raised my
take on Illinois versus [ __ ] again
it's Illinois hands down man you got the
ultimate army here we're talking street
smart people tech savvy and know their
way around a gun man at a gun range and
don't forget about all them thugs a kick
in your mama's door and duct tape them
babies without no questions asked why
you smiling though and if you try to hit
Chicago in the winter man it's
scientifically proven if you're not from
here your balls will freeze in less than
an hour try to walk around the city
Chicago in the wintertime and it's a
different kind of cold shy town
bear down gang gang brother in game dude
I do this thing called call thinker
which one of the things I do yeah Nick
Nick knows Nick's talk to me about it's
it's a fact the day it's all it is every
day it's like on Instagram it's just
called thinker into fact the day a fact
about that learned from doing that was
that did you know that Chicago is called
the Windy City not because of the wind
because the windy the company no because
uh is the blustery politicians oh really
blowing hot air oh really lyin huh
that's true yeah so everyone thinks is
because it's so windy off the lake but
it's because they were just a bunch of
liars oh wow and people getting fed up
with it and they nicknamed them yeah but
if you bring that up and it's windy as
[ __ ] and we're gonna give a [ __ ] tell
them that it's windy and they're
freezing no dude it's about the
politician that's a good [ __ ] dude I wish
I knew more facts man dude you should
follow thinker it's it's a great way to
just advance a general conversation if
you run out of things to talk about was
like yo did you did you know that uh the
Chicago you just hit him with oh yeah
hit him with that strike [ __ ] that [ __ ]
did that panty-dropper dude another
thing about Illinois yeah
how you say it I say Illinois because
that's how I say it too which means that
there's a silent s which is you know in
a lot of ways suspicious yeah I don't
know any other states that have silent
letters Wow and why would you need a
second stuff
Arkansas yeah right yeah nobody says
Arkansas and that's it and that's
evidence due to their hiding some you
think or they want you know what it's
like it's kind of like they wanna they
you know they know you know but they
just don't want you to say it well it's
Abe Lincoln country man you got as top
hats as people with [ __ ] balance and
[ __ ] tall hats on their heads for
decades that's the posture belt so
you're also looking at you know farmers
Chicago a lot of people shooting each
other up there you got some black on
black crime up there in the city but you
think the guy's railroad needs to let up
out there so you have a lot of like you
know civil rights a lot of you know you
do have some it's kind of the it's kind
of like the capital of the Midwest in a
way do you think Chicago is yeah
probably but I sometimes feel like
Chicago too is is uh they want to be
something they're not in a little in a
in a couple ways you know right like
they want to be what like New York or
they want to do I went to I went to
Hamilton I was with Mitch in Chicago we
went to they don't do Hamels in the
musical and we so we went in the morning
Wow
was it what was that like dude I fell
asleep yeah and I had and I thought it
was because I thought it was because uh
we had went out the night before right
and I was like you know what I just
didn't prepare but then I went back with
my parents in Chicago again because we
went to a game we want to watch them
play the Rams and we went to em again
and I almost fell asleep agin it's kind
of boring yeah
oh it looked boring it's a dude outfit
look boring but they got such good
reception the only thing I can think is
that it was really good in New York and
then when they went to Chicago Chicago
just can't I do it oh wow I can't hold
it down they can't even support [ __ ]
Hamilton but Michigan I mean when the
guy said is Michigan gonna stick
together you got you know we'll do it in
a lot of ways Illinois and Michigan are
the same state and the difference is
because they got
it's cold weather right great people
nice people right look some Lakes yep
some good schools yeah and uh and but
the difference is Michigan has has a bad
city Detroit right in Chicago Illinois
has a pretty great city sure there are
further for their capital yeah that's a
good point we think about that alone the
fact your capital where you're gonna
have everybody probably meet up yeah in
your top city Michigan's game like I
don't know if I'm going down there half
of your state is you like look I'm going
down there yeah you know if you have to
meet on an important issue right right
so I think that's a good point man I
think I'm gonna go with Illinois and my
[ __ ] and my little son out there
regional Theo dude and that's regional
to you the other one the only other
thing I can think about Michigan is that
all you already typed it in okay is it
too late no say your favor well we're
just gonna say in Michigan they also
have speaking of like kind of rough
cities Flint yeah which is uh we're
daddy long neck is from a boy [ __ ]
daddy long neck DL in boy let you make a
yeah legend but dude I think those guys
if these if you made it in Flint I mean
you've you've really uh you've proven
you can go through some things
yeah you and you know I hate to say this
but you've proven you can take a little
let you know saying yeah that's a good
point
daddy long net let me send him a little
video right now if you'll get back to me
so what was that enough damn long net
let's go to let's see what the people
said and let's FaceTime daddy long neck
real quick and see if he has any Intel
was that cool yeah because he is alive
right now in the meantime the people
said 55% said Michigan and 45% said
Illinois so all right let's get dead a
long neck in here
daddy is he active
oh I think he's safe I think would you
say he's probably notions like most
famous guy who DLN baby yeah [ __ ]
most famous guy Michigan's since that
guy that ran back to kick off for the
Wolverines rock Desmond Howard
there's no go go pack okay what's up
layer you on the podcast right now what
kind of dog is that
can you screen record that thing hey I
got a question for you uh long net what
about this man if ditch if Michigan and
Illinois the two states got into a war
who would win and why are they calling
mutter mitten oh yeah that murder men
were man I got my boy Caleb from
barstool here today with me man Sabra
yeah for sure yeah you got to go into
barstool sometime have you ever been
that he would you be a great person to
present the fact of the day I think yeah
you gang gang will do it man I'll
connect you and Caleb and I'll send you
his information
[Music]
alright how's your cousin doing good
gang brought like that [ __ ] fro boy
that's it [ __ ] nah brah I like both
y'all got different stuff man
word man will shout out to the murder
mitt and be good long neck gang bruh
there you go to murder mitt I mean
that's me that's Michigan alright you
heard a first and foremost and that's
daddy long neck dude man anything can
happen during state wars oh so now does
that mean we're gonna go to you Caleb
cuz you're the guest man does that
change the way you feel like they call
it murder mitten and you know Illinois
you know is different that's basically
daddy long necks said is that what he
said yeah yeah I mean I don't dude I
don't think I'm in the position to
refute anything he just said yeah I
think we should probably take his word
mashaallah murder mitt what a comeback
how'd you guys meet me and longneck yeah
Oh actually the crazy thing is we were
distant distant family members yeah
which is the craziest part of it all and
ironically Theo has always had a limited
neck so long next kind of his hero yeah
they've got that range boy we're crazy
in the rain son you know he can eat a
chocolate off his shoulder did you meet
him out of like a gathering oh no I mean
I know I've known you know I've known
that we have family for 15 years and
that's why they had a falling-out did
they
yeah because what's-his-name stole all
our money uh who was that guy um snappy
Pete or whatever that blond haired kid
is slappy smokey Danny or whatever they
predicted we should try to reconcile him
on the pod oh that wouldn't be bad okay
let's move on to the next one we have
Utah right Nick yes in yep in the the
West region regional final we have Utah
verse Cala Tana it was a pretty crazy
Colorado and Montana merged here is our
video for Utah hey what up Co Gang Gang
I saw I saw like a couple months
oh man big fan gap so yeah man you tall
the way a couple reasons why I know I
know they keep saying this but it's the
Mormon Church man they have so much
money they bring in you know seven
billion dollars a year and tithing alone
that's not to count everything else they
have the other thing is no one's
mentioned this but every once this war
breaks out man every Mormons going back
to Utah and there's another six million
in the u.s. so then you add that to the
population of ute already someone
already said this food storage when this
goes the Armageddon style and it goes no
electricity walking dead type [ __ ] then
it's gonna be food storage we have a ton
of Navajo here Tongans so when it comes
to that hand-to-hand combat with no
electricity we're gonna kick ass bro
yeah dude so anyways you tal the way
gang gang gang gang man that's the facts
so I didn't know Mormons liked to fight
like that the way he made a sound was
like the that's kind of what they what
they've been working on well you know I
don't know what they've been working on
but it sounds like that's what they've
been working on yeah that that's what
we've learned the past couple days all
Mormons are strapped they have a lot of
guns and food storage yeah they're
peaceful until they can't be until it's
time to not be peaceful like they will
defend I mean that's what takes a lot of
wars it ends up being about religion you
know and people that's when people will
fight when it tests whatever that thing
is in the base of them that really
challenges them you know and then and
the Mormons have that group I mean and
so a lot of Christians might well I
don't know if a lot of Christians would
band with the Mormons if things got if
it got down a religious no you know no
way right I feel like where these people
they're going out call a lab really
[ __ ] up about that right where they're
going against Carlo Tana which is is is
Colorado in Montana we had a lot of
whites yeah a lot of white Christians
yeah probably gonna be Christians I mean
it's gonna be a lot of white it's gonna
be people from those states I feel like
there's there's no one more judgmental
of the Mormon community than the
Christians Wow
but that money seven billion last year
he said I don't if that's true I believe
it because they all of them give ten
percent of their income to directly to
the church
that helps here's their guy for but how
much billions do they have that if
that's they have 70 billion as a group
that's like the whole GDP of the world
pretty successful people I don't know I
told you things and they don't have to
pay taxes Wow
like once they once they give them money
the there are religions so they're not
paying taxes that's true damn and they
have the food storage as part of their
religion is that they plan ahead like
that I mean part of the robe Aptus you
just got to bring someone Sunday could
be being you know like Bob wins they do
this can be out of your system right you
know [ __ ] hungry probably gonna be
what do we have here net this is a guy
for Collett Anna
all right here's what Cole Tonya will
definitely beat Utah Colorado
it's got Cowboys Montana a lot of
Indians Cowboys got guns usually Indians
bows and arrows and Utah it's got a lot
of Mormons a lot of Mormons what are
they gonna do stop an arrow and a bullet
with their [ __ ] Book of Mormon I don't
think so
that's why Cole Tonya will definitely be
Utah like I need to educate himself on
Mormons yeah it'll just have that seemed
insensitive a little bit yeah it seemed
insensitive which is that's a part of it
I actually kind of enjoyed also they
will let's have a meeting so that
everybody knows how to pronounce Kola
Tana as well I think I'm a roll with you
telling this man we actually had a late
entry some video came in this was a
surprise hello
Jesus Utah its petunia what are they
lazy disgust oh yeah whoa okay that's
Hannah oh hey we ride maybe we back from
the dead Virginia Utah we won't team up
and [ __ ] straight Merkel Itano
all you [ __ ] is dead Virginia get the
gangbangers
we got the drugs we get the Garland's we
get the military we had a government man
[ __ ] hello Donna
we wanna make Virginia and Utah over
Goethe damn uh I think you had to bring
them back I don't know what the rules
are dude I think you had to bring you
make the rules man
Magoo tall is what he's saying were they
in the same bracket Virginia within the
south and came out of nowhere of a
sudden dude bite yeah I don't know what
caught me Colorado Montana I don't know
anything about to be honest with you
dude I just know that it's a large state
and I know that there's there's a you
know probably a lot of people who have
take that change there's an in in it
Nick
I got a net you know take the NRA
virtute oh yeah
Wow gangster bro
I'll take four Guto over Collett Anna
man yeah especially with that
surprise-attack extra state yeah you
have the military over there you do have
ah what else you have in Virginia have
the CIA great roads you got weed a lot
of Aaron Brooks lives there the buffet
hunters it's his new show um I'll go
over the burger talk you go with that
Caleb yeah that's great let's see what
the fan said but that was before youy
fairness they didn't even know that we
were bringing back an entire state yeah
33 percent said Utah 67% Catana but yeah
like you said are we letting it get too
weird though you think I don't know dude
we only have one combined state right
now in the final four or yeah yeah
that's true thank you point that guy
came strapped I don't know who's he did
it to gun in the video you can't see on
the UH on the listening part audio but
he had two guns in the video okay gang
brah so it's gonna in the final first
Final Four matchup it's gonna be
Michigan versus verga but before we get
there we are in the East Regional final
New Jersey versus New York this is huge
and and you live over there
I live in New York oh here's this
someone hey Theo what's up your friend
Matt it's late at night I'm looking at
the brackets I see the New York and New
Jersey are facing off against one
another
I gotta go New Jersey all the way on
this one man I'm from Boston
Massachusetts and the island I don't
fear New Yorkers I worry about people
from New Jersey because everybody in New
York not everybody some people are
[ __ ] to the core but most people that
live in New York City choose to live
there they moved there they have no real
affiliation people from New York or I'm
rather excuse me New Jersey rather
[ __ ] were born there yeah they live
there
they're gonna die there yeah whether
they're from Newark New Jersey whether
they're from Asbury Park they're listen
to Bruce Springsteen they're listening
to Bon Jovi and they have a beautiful
state to go over a tree to most people
don't know Appalachian Trail runs
through Northwest New Jersey
they got mountains they got rivers they
got lakes this is the most important
point everything that goes into New Yor
New York comes through New Jersey if you
stop the 18-wheelers Wow New York's
gonna be suffocated in four days dude I
don't know dude I froze the other way I
live in New York
hmm I'm from North Carolina but I live
in New York I think that New Jersey
there might be a type of state that like
looks good coming off the bus yeah big
muscles yeah but not a lot of functional
strength right you know I'm saying okay
not a lot of core strength yeah it's a
lot of biceps not a lot of core yeah
you're right
because oh these guys are in New Jersey
these guys are they want to be in New
York they all their best things are New
York stuff and I'm not saying that as a
hater I love people but dude let's be
honest what's that what is there what's
the city that you know they don't the
only want anyone knows Newark it's a New
York Airport what is probably their
biggest resource the Giants and Jets for
milk also they have a lot of cattle New
Jersey water I think it's like a
resource or something lot of rain it
Sopranos The Sopranos yeah Toms River
that baseball team that try
every year the kid children softball
team look I agree what about this though
New Jersey I feel like New York City's
gotten so gentrified so rich whatever
you call it you know that there's not
you can't even get mugged anywhere
anywhere some problem Alphabet City
kidding me get [ __ ] stabbed they set
for an alphabet city the odds getting
shot in New York City anymore
you better [ __ ] you gonna have to
drive over though you know to New Jersey
right over to New Jersey right to really
get like Hoboken is kind of like a place
that regular people can forward to live
now right Brooklyn I mean that like dude
I saw some graffiti in there it was like
Larry sucks dick right in the urinal and
it said but only if he's okay with it
right like they're so [ __ ] liberal
looks like what the [ __ ] are they really
gonna like fight or throw down they're
gonna pick it they're gonna protest but
now didn't you get up to Rochester do
with that's the overdose belt bro up in
the ROC do with [ __ ] people listen to
brother wheeze and a morning on a radio
and eating dirty Italian and celebrating
st. Patrick's Day 9 times a year
[ __ ] with the neck tattoos and
[ __ ] square wheeled rollerskates
those and other [ __ ] are getting bent
brah you get up into there and in me the
SUNY schools dude that's [ __ ] rape
country brah what does this guy have to
say hey Theo it's Mike from Rochester
New York all day New Jersey's stupid
they're gonna be attack in New York City
because they think that's the capital
and they can they we don't mind we're
just gonna send out them rats from the
subways we're gonna get those soft
gentle whites Creed um help New York
City with their problem and then that's
when the real action that's when upstate
New York comes and helps and wipes out
New Jersey you know we got Sarah Q's
Albany you got Rochester yeah which one
we're poverty and we got some real
killers in the city so I mean [ __ ]
around we don't even need buffalo
Buffalo can just come and supply the
beer and wings am i right okay gang
Buffalo's got Thurman Thomas where you
give him a gun you'll [ __ ] run
through the whole [ __ ] state it's a
tough one this is very tough dude
there's a lot dude there's a lot of in
New York there's wide use
and yes Jade uh and they and you know
they don't believe in afterlife they
don't have if they die if they go down
right done but we are you talking
American Jews you talking Israelis like
an Israeli guy I'm afraid of a new
American Jews gonna hire somebody to die
for him you know oh yeah yeah wait or
they're just uber drivers a lot of uber
drivers who I feel like a lot of them
came here to avoid this type of
situation right which is a travesty for
them put that I will say this New Jersey
has one thing going for them that have
Long Island yeah and Long Island for New
Jersey is a truly a Trojan horse because
I've been to Long Island I have a lot of
friends from wrong a Long Island I had
an intern who was from Long Island yeah
they call it everything wrong Island
balling Islands wrong on in your Long
Island and you know what it is though
what New Jersey in New York is a Trojan
horse it is through the people in Long
Island they're from New Jersey they are
for sure yeah it's a one place they can
still get in in New York and be a part
of it you know when the [ __ ] hits the
fan I mean New York's already shown they
[ __ ] you know a couple of Slim's
[ __ ] drove a couple of airplanes into
the damn buildings you know so they've
already shown that they can't [ __ ]
hold it down really if [ __ ] gets hectic
but dude also living in New York this is
from personal experience it's already
kind of like wartime conditions yeah
because you travel underground you know
it's a very expensive a lot of taxes and
fees for everything right and don't see
the Sun for long periods of time yeah I
do think that that extensive subway
system could really come in handy
mmm that's true that's a good point and
that's just the city though now you
gotta get out into the rest of it
the thing about western New York New
Jersey's huge people realize that the
thing about western New Jersey what's
out there Milliken Lehigh you know tons
of [ __ ] the amateur out there they
got all kinds of wildness out there you
know it's tough to know what how its
gonna break down Lehigh University's in
New Jersey I think so I might I guess I
never knew it but there are 16 seed it
could be Lee I could be in PA we're
gonna let you call this when Kayla
Presley dude I think
I would feel real bad saying New Jersey
when I live in New York you know I'm
saying that's kind of like wishing
wishing wishing bad on yourself I must
say in New York and I'm saying New York
and I and I have a lot of respect for
people in New Jersey but I think New
York probably takes a good yeah I'll
probably say that to just shout out to
even as being up in Rochester you know
these people are either their main food
of sustenance it's called garbage plates
so they could eat right out the dumpster
run and be right at home
alright I'll roll with New York alright
our last regional final florid gia the
combined of Florida and Georgia versus
the number one Texas see what some video
submissions we got here hey Theo hey
Nick just want to get a quick vote in
for Florida however you say that um I'm
all office so I'm having to talk quietly
but looking at the population even
though Texas is bigger Florida and
Georgia have more crazy people so I know
we would be fighting to the death as
well as okay if you don't stop you'll
Asian together we're at 31.8 and Texas
is only at twenty eight point seven so
crazies and more people if you add us
together so chanting I'll tell you from
walesska Georgia in game eleska thank
you very much young lady well let's have
a hottie [ __ ] send in something huh
yeah not bad dude she looked like she
was a big fan too oh yeah dude she
seemed like a sweet lady kind of lady
you definitely wouldn't mind you know
starting a future together this is David
from Houston Texas
what's up Theo games you wanting to give
a shout out to all the truck drivers out
there and want to leave a comment about
Texas and Florida matchup just one day I
gotta say about Texas man we fought for
our independence that's all I had to
mention man thanks so they've already
done it well then what was that was that
the Alamo I guess who knows I mean it
but Texas Texas yeah they fought for
their independence dude apparently
remember the Alamo they didn't get it
do so Florida and Georgia all combined
that legit amount of this is still
interesting or the most boring material
but also I said this with a gap again I
think years from now this could be a
reference that people use that's how
crazy the world's getting this might
happen
could you see us going to state
governments I could see it and I would I
would support it I would - especially if
they told me that there was a reason why
we it would work yeah why not dude what
I don't long as you can travel from
state to state who cares Yeah right
except some sage might be like a [ __ ]
yank coming over here you know bill that
yeah well there's probably some states
that probably exited in the first round
who there you know if they're not part
of the United States they probably lose
a lot of what they have right but those
are you know those are some of the
weaker states right these are top tier
states we're talking about yeah these
are talk to your states I mean
Florida and being associated with
Georgia I think legitimizes Florida in a
lot of ways mmm
I could see that because I mean Florida
I think a lot of people myself included
kind of think of it as a another place
it's kind of like oh yeah almost like an
Australia type vibe when you go yeah and
I would be interested to see maybe if we
could look up Nick some War records of
Australia how they do mmm because I
think that could probably go they were
in one more Mel Gibson was in it and I
think he he and his brother actually
ended up making up at the end it's
called Gallipoli so there you go
and also I like what you're saying it
legitimizes Florida cuz like I think of
Georgia as like southern like it's like
classy like there's Southern gentleman
stuff so yeah and definitely a lot of
people from General Sherman's march to
the sea or still living there
descendants of that over there in
Georgia you didn't have a lot of pride
for that oh I think so I think you're
gonna immediately see I mean it's gonna
be a lot of like there's a lot that
coastal area over there Jack so there's
a lot of military all along there one
guy in his video said Texas has the
number one amount of enlisted people
living in their state too
well dude if this happens you're gonna
have to literally hold tryouts and Tech
and Dallas Cowboys there's so many
people that want to fight I'll go with
Texas then if that's the case then yeah
and they I will say Texas they came out
video wise like the most by far
submissions
yeah yeah dude and also Florida doesn't
have any anybody over like the age of 30
like if you go there everyone's already
died from from like a you know they've
got a lot of drugs right 30 or under 80
or over and over 30 dies on that show
the first 48 we'll do it a few if he was
in Miami if you they they have to import
their old people yeah because if you're
from Florida like you have no chance
that's a good point action look at skin
cancer above watch plastic surgery bro
you're done off about oh yeah yeah
somebody put an ass cheek into some
guy's throat and [ __ ] almost killed it
so Texas does it I think Texas does it
this is our final for New York let's do
Texas Michigan and for guta really came
out of nowhere no one would have guessed
that I think for guta like that so let's
start in Michigan verse for Goethe no
videos to Michigan I mean really all we
have to go on out of her Goethe was it
was that one get the strength that one
God first of all is the first killer who
was sent in a video the guy was
camouflaged up wearing different things
to prevent us from seeing him and had
more than one gun real guns person can
we look at the states what they look
like some facts about Michigan dude II
know what's crazy hmm Michigan have you
ever seen what it looks like a mitten
yeah but this is the thing he didn't
tell you and this is the thing I didn't
really know and so pretty recently
uh-huh they already took over like half
of Wisconsin he not even though really
dude if you look at a map do see it see
how the it's red up top the U P Gaffney
was talking about there's no there's no
reason that should be called Michigan
it's separated by a body of water and it
just like they secretly took over some
of Wisconsin that wisconsin wasn't
utilizing properly gang bro I think they
gave us a choice between Door County the
thumb of Wisconsin and u P and we took
dork and that's a thumb that cloud looks
more like a bottle opener but if you
have Virginia cruising all the way
across to [ __ ] roll with Utah also do
this just that one guy
that's true maybe definitely look like
he was murder specific but that one guy
in Utah could really flank Michigan
being they get there on both sides of it
I forget who's who's Virginia flanken
I'm trying to fish against Michigan yeah
some other stats right here about some
of the places I want to look at really
fast Utah has more regular church
attendance than any other state I want
to let you know whooping cough is huge
over there in actually that's in
Wisconsin but engineers Michigan has a
lot of engineers in it Virginia is the
home of bad driver sucess and that's not
a racial slur dude here's his thumb
about Utah I feel like if the war where
does it take go down because if it takes
place in Utah here's something I know
for a fact you're not gonna be able to
fight in a lot of the state those are
national parks oh wow protected areas
you can't chant war in a national park
dude and this is a war but we're not
we're not crazy yeah now all somebody's
trying to have a split of sandwich for
this time in a tent so this is gonna
have to happen you know in Michigan
Michigan Utah what do you think man what
do you think Caleb you're the one who's
got to take us through this I hate to
say it I'll go ahead and I'm gonna say
this I have a tremendous amount of
respect for the guy who called in and
basically got you talk to the next round
and reestablished Virginia in this
tournament which I don't even know at
what point they were eliminated but are
we gonna are we gonna really just off
the strength of this one guy and the
passion of this one guy and he was
intimidating are we gonna let them go
all the way to the final or a Michigan
is a real state I mean at the end of the
day dude you're talking about a real
state that exists that's a good point
yeah and I you you brought it up and we
brought her up in past episodes the fact
that they were able to survive through
that radio a shout-out to bleed water
like they're stronger in Flint yeah well
even daddy longneck called in and said
it's called murder me yeah I already
forgot about that dude definitely
Michigan I don't forget that
cousin Allen keith was on there too
alright let's roll it in then Michigan
it is man real Cinderella story I don't
think anybody when this tournament
started with us at Michigan I was going
all the way
I wouldn't even I still can't believe I
am I think it might we might be going to
a anti-climatic exchange New York versus
Texas Kayla Presley New York first Texas
all right did you guys ever play Texas
when you guys are either one of these
states when you were a UNC not know
would it be your experience with
barstool have you noticed anything at
these places Texas I've been I'm trying
to think what I've done I've been - I've
been to Texas actually I went down there
you know vote so I went down to do a
video this year because their coach
coach Herman yeah was before the games
were starting he was kissing the players
oh yeah
you saw it oh I didn't see it but I
believed it but it's like I was
supported so I went down there and I was
kind of doing like almost an
investigative journalist ik piece of of
why why are we kissing players and why
are we only kissed on the cheek like
let's get serious you want to win some
games
oh yeah that's crazy man and that shows
you there's love right there in the
heart of Texas dude I'll tell you this
New York [ __ ] half of New York would
overdose on their way across the data
that's beautiful half an you put
overdose all your boys from Rochester
you're gonna overdose in the desert on
the way down there they're gonna
overdose even just heading down there I
think Texas is gonna have some severe
move they're gonna be mobile they're
gonna have a strong Latino contingency
can you imagine how many people in Texas
if it does go to war that are gonna say
told you so
they've already man Oh guys this is
pretty easy honestly it's definitely
Texas yeah yeah this is Texas a thing
why would a juggernaut Texas Michigan
fine which is a great football game this
um you might see on January 1 oh this is
a great football game right here and
this game happened didn't it with uh
when Vince McMahon was a quarterback or
no no that was there's no chance that's
right yeah
[ __ ] yeah you're right okay Michigan
versus Texas we had one video for just
general Texas okay now I'm not from
Texas I'm from Louisiana but I know for
a fact that Texas is gonna win this
entire bracket they are almost 30
million people and think about this they
don't already beaten all the people
around him you know that for a fact
they've barely had any casualties they
also got our poncho and brothers to
south now all this combined you already
know they're gonna be beating whoever is
under way that's a gang gang and getting
brother I appreciate that that's true
man
I mean Michigan you're gonna have
tetanus the tetanus scare alone from
them on struggling with drug use and
trying to make weapons in those old
rusted-out factories mm-hmm it's gonna
be it's gonna be sick a lot of what do
you think is gonna make children a lot
of people you know a lot of biracial
kids who don't know what's going on are
gonna need therapy probably before they
can even get out of the state you know
are they gonna band together
kill best an interesting question where
will the the war play out this final
battle I think Nebraska is kind of right
in the middle just flat land I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of cities
in Texas I feel like are kind of it kind
of wouldn't matter if it happened there
yeah it's just I think it would be the
same it's not like the city's bad but
it's just kind of safe yeah you are
gonna have a strong Latino contingency
you know you're gonna have who knows how
many people are really in Texas too if
you count the hidden illegal aliens from
I mean they could be anywhere from
anywhere Canada Mexico maybe anywhere
and do there's tycoons there oil tycoons
yeah which I used to play this game when
I was growing up on the computer called
rollercoaster tycoon and I don't think
they're actually correlated or similar
but dude fantastic game really yeah you
really felt like you were I think a
tycoon is just someone who's very
successful in business
and I think an oil tycoons I can only
imagine them coming in on a horse yeah
yeah and really kind of establishing
their dominance and you don't waste time
who's our leader right you know that
Coons a leader
well Jerry Jones and then they're
helping him yeah oh and Jerry Jones got
ultimate you know we got a real profit
factory running over there with them
Dallas Cowboys I'm sure letters Brian
didn't tycoon play for the black sacks
was any part of blacks guys I'm not sure
I could do this talk yeah well we agree
on that
I just this round right now and I just
think Michigan just falls apart at this
point I think it's just been too much
for them to to handle you know they took
on Iowa they took on Nebraska you know
they'd be Kentucky Illinois for Guto I
mean it's probably nine people left dude
and two of them are listening to Kid
Rock and the other ones Eminem and when
the other one is imminent and he's not
coming out the house
no he isn't he's flip-flopping so much
on what he's about I think I would say
Texas yeah I think I had a great point
about not a lot of casualties they had
to buy they steamrolled through a couple
rounds there they're fresh yeah that's
it my vote I'm not gonna decide your
entire tournament this is your
tournament this is this past weekend
stay Wars but my vote is Texas there you
go Texas it is Wow that's it and Caleb
works for barstool and he also played
backup quarterback to a younger man so
if anybody is qualified if I can pick
who should win the war up all the states
to me it's definitely him in this row I
would like to put it out to the fans if
anybody wants to put together a montage
of all five episodes and put it to one
shining moment I think that would be
incredible that's like my favorite part
of the NCAA tournament every year some
Luther Vandross and these wars play out
I think it could really really be
beautiful that would but people use as a
reference point yeah I think we use that
as commercial for next year too and I
think next year maybe we'll do the
brackets different if we put them in a
different you know come out it just we
actually rank them I think there's a
chance that certain states could lose to
other states and it's also depending on
who's in
in the in the shotgun seat here hey dude
I'm looking at North Carolina get
eliminated first round I don't know how
that happened
yeah a lot of people don't man I don't
know how West Virginia got put out yeah
they didn't feel it for sure where did
you want and you have an old lady you
said huh yeah and where'd you meet her
at and sorry to ask you about I met her
at North Carolina but I really didn't
start dating her until New York oh wow
well you better pass and kind of yeah oh
wow she works at SoulCycle
oh yeah he told me that and that's
reading that Russell Brand been a big
day man dude oh it's been a great day
yeah this is gonna go down in history
and we dude I know we're kidding about
this is gonna be called for reference
who's kidding yeah
oh it easily could be well I I think
that this is something that at the very
least we made some salient points about
these states that it's kind of kind of
time for self-reflection in a lot of
ways for some of the guys well I could
see it I mean look some states in some
areas are really pulling the weight for
other areas and and also of different
places have different ideas of what
pulling the weight means some people
think pulling the weight is working hard
some people think pulling the weight is
being you know in Tennessee that's just
going to Dollywood yeah yeah that's it
yeah some people think it's just
different stuff you know taking care of
their kids making money having a job
people think it's all different stuff so
and also like shout out the people in
Texas I have some some good friends from
Texas good people but just because you
won state Wars I'm not sure that's a
shining endorsement of your state that
we think that you're gonna be the best
at em mass genocide right yeah I read a
quote this just this morning actually
war doesn't decide who's right it
decides who's left who has the most guns
and we already knew that was Texas oh
really
as in remaining left oh wow dang it's
crazy dude a lot of quotes they should
put what it means after you know I read
a quote I'm like what is this about you
know yeah one time I was in a that was
like a first class first day of class at
Carolina and our teacher handed out a
page of full of quotes like Albert
Einstein Isaac Newton the gauntlet of
quote people and then one that was just
like a cam member was like HB Scott and
she's like raise your hand and tell me
something about one of these quotes and
I raise my hand trying to get in her
good graces I was like HB Scott
quote is straight-up stupid like it
doesn't make any sense
and she was like that's me that's me
she was HP Scott yeah she put herself
amongst amongst the great crazy move
dude I remember when I went into some
class and they told us about Stonehenge
you know and like what does it mean
we're gonna find out and I was like what
if God was just [ __ ] with everybody
just set some rocks up you know
and ladies I get first day and I thought
it was like fun you know a fun way to
talk about and just as it possible as
anything else yeah so I'm saying man who
knows what if the Lord does dominoes
Kaitlin Presley thanks for coming and
helping us get through the state we're
sorry I'm a little bit tired today man I
think I would have more energy but you
know we did it Joe thanks for having me
dude
it's been a it's been great and yeah we
got to come back over there in Barstow
and do your daddy longneck oh look I'm
gonna connect you guys in just a few
minutes man hey hey that murder murder
damn it you know that kinda murder me
anthe was gonna be announcing Jionni
fightin rough if you want to do that you
actually you should do that who could
who would he fight though let's pick a
fight right now and Jionni's the young
kind of twink guy who books our show and
he's also gonna be in a movie with
Octavia Spencer in about six weeks
shut up yeah but he's also the young
twin got that books are selling we pay
him in me on DS but look that's what God
wants well you know who he fights I've
seen it all in West Virginia dude I've
seen two identical twins both named
Bubba yeah fight each other I've seen in
Myrtle Beach I saw a overweight I don't
know if it's over weights the right word
but a cam girl mm-hmm and I hope they're
trained and she left she lost she lost
damn I've seen it all so we can't
probably make it happen with whoever if
you want to see a see him get his ass
beat we can make the happen or if you
want to see him you know make a good
name for your podcast we can make that
happen you'd like you said it
Gianni Shore and he's he's stock he's
built I would love to see him fight like
a tall lanky black eye I think that
would be a fun yeah trying to be
exciting or black woman yeah I think we
have women yeah well just a really tan
guy dude there's no rules is the other
thing that there's like
no like oh you're 300 pounds and you're
180 girl yeah
I'm not actually they don't do guys
verse gross but pretty much everything
else was like fair game but if it's a
really tough girl I could see it I could
see them going toe-to-toe if she's tall
and if maybe she played at least d2
basketball does that cam girl want to
come back maybe that could be the
matchup she came back as her as a ring
girl so know instead of fighting so we
have ring girl competition too so she
was like twerking and I did a split and
race she's flexible somebody's gonna
give I just sounds like a bug and this
sounds like a me to claim wait and have
another that's us that's me and her Wow
like how you part your hair like that
thanks dude no she she actually dumped
him out right before it's pay-per-view
so you can have a little bit of nudity I
think a wild pay-per-view yeah so she
dumped them out rough and rowdy if
you're gonna miss it by the time this
podcast comes out we're doing it this
Friday but did your listeners would love
it West Virginia you're going to us or
any of this Friday I'm going straight
there Wow
we'll put it on on this past weekend
Instagram at least yeah I mean it we
have them though we do it a couple times
a year
yeah dude seriously you should come and
you should you should call his fight if
that's all you want to do and just check
it out maybe next year we'll get Johnny
and we'll see maybe we could have him
fight another someone else or another
podcast
yeah like fight Bobby Lee's little
brother that I think something's wrong
with him but we could have them fight
TVB
yeah Stevie we be first of all nobody's
last name is [ __ ] we be you know
Kelly Presley thanks so much man we'll
we'll do this again soon bro appreciate
appreciate tell Kevin and the other guy
are the Francis and other fellow with
red hair what's his name Donovan Daniel
Oh John final Burke John Fido bird is he
the one you were saying that you thought
was gay no I was a different guy in
there I met real quick but um tell him I
said hey man interesting I can't wait I
want to talk to you after this and just
find out who - well we've discussed a
lot I feel like we probably will talk
next time we'll chat after but uh thank
you very much Rob let's get to the end I
think that's it Texas number one you
know perfect so if [ __ ] gets if [ __ ]
hits the [ __ ] fan you know where to
go one
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]